this is sky news breakfast these are our
top stories this morning
all remaining covert restrictions in
england are to be dropped this week as
the prime minister proposed to announce
his plan to live with the virus
[Music]
the legal duty to self-isolate is to end
but labor criticizes the move and asks
to see the evidence behind the decision
joe biden is to convene a national
security council meeting today as
tensions continue on the ukrainian
border with liz trust warning putin
won't stop with ukraine
team gb strike gold at the winter
olympics the women's curling team taking
the title in beijing
plus unpicking the sharp rise in poor
mental well-being in farmers as new
figures suggest younger workers are more
at risk
the clear-up from storm eunice continues
with public transport disrupted around
the country and thousands still without
power
the weather today wind and heavy rain
will spread south eastwards with yellow
warnings in place for much of the
country
and at quarter two we'll take a look
through the morning's papers with the
former editor of the daily star dawn
nissan and the journalist and
broadcaster padisha
[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast the legal duty to self-isolate
in england after testing positive for
the coronavirus will end this week with
boris johnson set to announce his living
with covet plan the prime minister will
lay out his plan to end all covert
restrictions in england to mps when they
return to parliament but labour have
criticized the move asking downing
street to publish the evidence behind
the decision skies over bennett reports
for two years coveted restrictions have
been part of our lives affecting almost
every aspect but by the end of next week
in england it's expected they will all
be scrapped including the need to
self-isolate after a positive test as
part of a plan for living with covid
in a statement the prime minister said
we need to learn to live with this virus
and continue to protect ourselves
without restricting our freedoms
thanks to our successful vaccination
program and the sheer magnitude of
people who have come forward to be
jabbed we are now in a position to set
out our plan for living with covid this
week
vaccines the government says will be the
main defense with virus surveillance
scaled back and local authorities
charged with managing outbreaks this
scientist is among those who thinks it's
too soon to remove self-isolation
either thought that we should have kept
that in place really for the next few
months whilst we're going through
relatively high levels of infection
within the country
while we are not exactly sure when new
variants are going to be popping up so
i'm very i have to say i'm really
nervous about it
and he's not alone alison pearson and
her daughter isabel are among the 3.7
million considered clinically extremely
vulnerable they'll be offered treatments
but still don't feel safe it feels very
much like we're on our own this time and
there are many millions of us um who are
just having to walk this tight rape
of trying to navigate every single
situation and work out what the risk is
[Music]
for the hospitality sector though the
risk also brings reward this restaurant
in london is predicting a 30 percent
boost to business
we have missed a lot of guests they
couldn't come because they had to
isolate themselves for you know 10 days
whatever it is
but now yeah we are very happy
while the government's plan looks
forward many can't help but look back
sharon hooton's great aunt nancy is
among the 160 000 covid victims
memorialized on the embankment opposite
parliament it's when you're putting
somebody like our nan
at risk i think it's
no not right personally
returning to life before the pandemic
simply isn't possible not just for those
who have lost loved ones but for all of
us kovid will forever be part of our
lives the question is how big a part
from next week that will depend on us as
individuals
iva bennett sky news
let's bring in our correspondent melinda
vasilenovich who's in the newsroom for
us us this morning good morning melena
it's quite a moment isn't it and it's
already being met with mixed reaction
good morning kimberly big moment where
england will shift to relying solely on
vaccines and medical treatments to keep
people safe and local authorities will
be required to treat a covet outbreak as
they would any other infectious disease
outbreak now the pm spokesman was
previously asked if that means that
people should go to work with covet and
the answer was that that wasn't
something that they would recommend so
you get the sense that boris johnson
would like people to start treating
coward like the flu so you might not go
into work if you're feeling really bad
or you might be a bit more careful
around people who are elderly but the
difference with covert is of course that
sometimes people don't have any symptoms
and we've also heard rumors that the
free lateral flow tests might stop
although that hasn't been confirmed as
of yet and that's being criticized if it
does go ahead because if people don't
know that they're sick then how can they
take precautions and also if you have to
pay for it that will deepen health
inequalities now we haven't had anything
on these new rules by boris johnson from
either chris whitty the chief medical
officer or sir patrick valens the chief
scientific officer however three
quarters of nhs leaders said in a survey
that they didn't agree with the
scrapping of self-isolation according to
the nhs confederation
but for those businesses of course who
have suffered so long with either covet
staff absences or not being able to plan
because of shifting regulation this is
welcome news
okay milena thank you so much
well let's look at the latest cover 19
figures as the pm prepares to do away
with all those restrictions another 34
377 cases have been recorded in the last
24 hours and another 128
people have died that takes the total
number of people who've died within 28
days of a positive test to 160 thousand
five hundred and seven
well in response to the government's
proposals the shadow health secretary
west streeting has said that boris
johnson is declaring victory before the
war is over you can hear more of what he
has to say he's going to join trevor
phillips at 8 30 this morning
now the u.s president joe biden will
convene a national security council
meeting today to discuss the rising
tension between russia and ukraine it
comes as the foreign secretary liz truss
warns president putin will not stop at
ukraine but is looking to rebuild the
soviet union sky's john sparks reports
now from eastern poland where nato is
bolstering its forces near the border
with ukraine
it is an unsettling sight an astonishing
scene in a place that knows the perils
of war
u.s troops with guns and gear on the
ground in eastern poland
3 thousand troops will make camp here in
a community called yashanka
although the soldiers have given it a
new name
[Applause]
it's j-town now with the local arena
serving as their barracks
this deployment is symbolic it's a
signal of strength as the russian
military threatens ukraine
but it's difficult to know what vladimir
putin will do as nato builds up its
forces
this sleepy regional airport has begun
to resemble a sophisticated military
encampment and that constitutes a clear
rejection of one of moscow's key demands
that nato pull its forces out of eastern
europe
and it could exacerbate tensions with
the russians even further
for the polls this is proof of a new age
of conflict a contest that will require
europe to re-on
but there is gratitude here for nato
support
actually i think it's the first time in
history that anglo-saxon troops have
come to poland potentially to defend us
against the foreign aggressor so big day
it's a clear signal to mr putin and his
generals that this is where nato
territory starts and it will be defended
and on a quick visit to the capital the
u.s defense secretary restated his
support announcing the sale of tanks and
planes to the polls
you know it's ironic that
what mr putin
did not want to see happen was a
stronger nato
on his flank
and that's exactly what he will see
going forward
two million ukrainians have made poland
their home working or studying at
universities
but these students in jesus are finding
it difficult to concentrate
i have family there
i also have a father in the military i
am trying to filter the information so
i'm trying not to panic like as most
people do and there is a question every
ukrainian in poland asks what do they do
if russia invades
personally i would
take my mom from ukraine
i i know that there are actually
movements that say that they want to
stay to stay in ukraine
whenever
whatever would happen
but i will take my mom
for sure to poland
but this was upsetting for yurina she
feels they have a duty to return is it
very bad
okay i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i didn't
plan to be honest like my first thought
when i realized that something like this
can be happen it's what it was like i
will go back home like uh i don't know
why like people are escaping i want to
go back i don't know uh why
like i know why because i love my
country
but
the invasion of ukraine seems
unthinkable to some but the polls have
begun to prepare
refugees will be welcomed and the
military stands ready to defend
john sparks sky news in jesus
let's bring in our defense editor
deborah haynes who's in kiev for us this
morning
interesting day yesterday deborah at
that munich conference where do we stand
today
well it's it's getting to that period
where you've had these warnings from the
us from the uk from nato repeated
warnings
increasingly stark as well in terms of
their belief that
president vladimir putin is going to
evade has decided to invade and that
invasion will happen according to the
u.s president this week he also said
that he believes according to u.s
intelligence that this city kiev will be
one of the targets but in terms of the
actual timing one of the key dates that
has been on people's minds is today the
20th of february and that's because it's
the day that the beijing olympics
finished and there had been talk from
senior u.s officials earlier on in this
crisis speculating that president putin
wouldn't want to launch an invasion of
ukraine
when his key ally uh president xi
jinping was um hosting such an in such a
big global event as the as the winter
olympics well that excuse uh or that
reason for restraint ends today and
another factor is that today is the day
when these huge and highly unusual
military acts exercises by russia in
belarus
are due to finish and the force in
belarus is the force that has caused
probably the most concern amongst uh
western officials who have been looking
at the lay down of troops around the
country because that is the force that
would be used would president putin
choose to attack the capital so any sign
of those troops moving back would be
seen i imagine um as a as a sign of
relief uh but if they don't then it
really means that he has the ability to
launch an invasion should he do so so
that's basically where we are in terms
of the actual military side of things
from the russia perspective but in the
east there have been again incredibly
worrying signs that western officials
again have said would happen ahead of an
invasion what are they well we've had an
increase of shelling in the uh from the
russia-backed separatist
side of territory towards ukrainian
controlled areas we've also had this
spike in disinformation so fake news
being amplified by russian media outlets
according to western officials i
reported yesterday that uh western
officials believe that the actual volume
of that disinformation being spread in
russian media has doubled in the last
week and we've also had cyber attacks
there were cyber attacks against um
websites
last week in ukraine the ukrainians say
the biggest denial of service attacks in
history so all key indicators that would
point to potential escalation but as yet
things are pretty calm
okay deborah thank you
and we will be getting more on that
story this morning with the europe
minister james cleverley that's on
trevor phillips on sunday 8 30 this
morning
now travellers are continuing to face
disruption across the uk in the wake of
storm eunice and the clear-up effort is
set to be hampered with more wet and
windy weather forecasts for today i'm
joined now by the director of network
rail jake kelly mr kelly it's good to
speak to you again thanks for joining us
so where are we where are we today in
terms of if you're traveling what should
you do
well our engineers have been working
again overnight to fix things up put
wires back fix up stations cut down even
more trees uh and we do expect uh almost
all of the network to open as a plan
this morning but but have been
inevitably with with the forecast today
there will be more disruption uh and our
strong advice to
customers is to check before they travel
and that applies particularly to the
northwest of england
south wales and the southwest
last time we spoke um you were telling
people on friday just don't travel don't
travel at all so now here we are on
sunday how bad was the damage and what
have you had to do to deal with all of
that
the damage was enormous and widespread
with thousands of trees and debris and
and trampolines and roofs and all sorts
of other things blown around
the track we've had enormous effort
involving thousands of people to pick
all of that up and to put the
infrastructure back together today we do
expect most of the railway to be
operational but inevitably with with the
forecasts it will be sadly disrupted
again i know that's very disappointing
for our our passengers and i do urge
them to to check uh before they travel
what about tomorrow morning when
everyone wants to get back to work do
you think that there's still going to be
disruptions and should people also
perhaps um think again about traveling
tomorrow
we'll do our absolute best to keep the
railway open tomorrow for our passengers
we know people rely on us enormously
but you're right that the forecast is
poor again tomorrow so my advice remains
the same do check before you set out to
make sure that your train will be
running what about the backlog
does do you have the same kind of effect
as
say
airline travel when you have a whole day
of people not traveling
it's a little bit different but we have
exactly the same problem with uh
displacement of trains
and train crew and that's a little bit
of what we saw yesterday when we get
them back into the right place uh to
start uh up uh efficiently and that's
what was happening all of yesterday uh
today and and and get us ready for
tomorrow morning
again has it cost you a lot of money
well it's it has cost a lot of money in
common with with
lots of other providers of
infrastructure in the country but you
know our focus is is getting our railway
open again for our passengers we know
passengers rely on us it's really
important that we get it open running
as smoothly as we possibly can
notwithstanding the very poor weather
that continues to be forecast
okay mr kelly thanks a lot for talking
to us
now some good news from beijing great
britain have won their first gold medal
of the winter olympics after the women's
curling team beat japan to take the top
prize on the ice
jackie joins me now for more
they did it fantastically
finally the best till last yes they did
and it's the fourth time of asking for
eve your head and she was so emotional
at the end they beat japan
in the final it was an annihilation
really 10-3 um nothing like their
semi-final
tight tight match against the reigning
olympic champions sweden which is we
will go down in history as perhaps one
of the greatest curling matches of all
time
this was team gb in control from start
to finish so eve vicky wright jen dodds
and hayley duff and
obviously it's eve's fourth olympics but
it was the first olympics for the other
girls and a tremendous achievement after
a very very long tournament they started
brilliantly uh went straight into the
lead
in this match they led 4-1 after five
ends they got a four
in the seventh and that pretty much all
but killed it i mean japan were chasing
this match from the very beginning they
were very much the favorites going into
it japan
sneaks really into the semi-finals um
having beaten
the world champions switzerland so gb
i guess were expected to win this match
but they won it comprehensively and we
should point out they were quite patchy
throughout this olympics uh this team it
took a while for them to get going i
mean they had five wins and four defeats
they only just got into the semi-finals
but they seemed to bring their best game
right at the end brilliant in the
semi-finals even more brilliant in the
final and that is what a good team
should do right you should build
throughout the tournament and save your
best to last and that's what they did
they are the olympic champions eve of
course was the flag bearer at the start
of the olympics it must seem a very long
time ago for her i mean this is an
incredibly long tournament and i guess
relief
incredible emotion at the end because
she was crying on the podium i think you
can almost see in that picture she looks
a little bit sort of teary and i'm sure
they're exhausted absolutely emotionally
and physically drained after that but it
was all worth it because they've got the
goals to match the silver that the guys
won yesterday so well done to great
britain's curlers and
what a triumph for scotland as well i
just want to say that
fantastic jackie thanks a lot
well let's have a look at some of this
morning's other stories now and police
in ottawa have dispersed the main
portion of protesters blockading the
canadian parliament over the
government's pandemic restrictions
dozens of arrests were made by police in
riot gear who used pepper spray and stun
grenades to clear the area
a passenger who was among the missing
after a blaze on a ferry between greece
and italy has been found to be alive
that's according to a greek shipping
ministry official rescue teams are
searching for at least 11 people after
the euro fell euro ferry olympia vessel
burst into flames on friday night
two people were left injured after a
helicopter crashed into the sea off
miami beach
oh
video tweeted by miami beach police show
the aircraft falling into the ocean
meters away from a crowd of swimmers
police say the two injured have been
taken to hospital they're in a stable
condition a third passenger wasn't
injured the beach was closed and a
federal investigation is underway that's
a lucky escape you see how that i look
up helicopters flip
time now for the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so today's wind and rain may bring some
disruption and hamper the clear up after
storm units there will be outbreaks of
rain to start the day heavy in the north
and west but parts of southern england
do look dry it's going to be windy and
mostly mild but chilly in the far north
heavy rain will become more organized
across ireland northern ireland and
northern england during the morning
elsewhere southern britain will stay
cloudy with patchy rain extending into
southern england meanwhile scotland can
expect a mix of sunshine and blustery
showers some wintry on the hills and it
is going to stay mild for many hello
again now over the last two years
farmers have faced extreme weather
conditions poor harvests
supply chain shortages and a global
pandemic that's taken not only a
physical but also a mental toll 92
percent of farmers under the age of 40
rank poor mental health as the biggest
problem they face today skies emma
virtually reports
three years ago matt stiles and his wife
took the big step of starting their own
farm in north cambridgeshire from
scratch
but juggling a full-time job employed as
a farmer to guarantee a wage whilst also
caring for his own sheep pigs and
poultry has taken its toll i've sort of
been
presented with these feelings of anxiety
and worry and sleeplessness and you know
low moods and things and kind of thought
why am i feeling like this there's this
sort of stigmatized almost toxic trait
within agriculture that you have to be
tough
and you know you live a tough outdoorsy
way of life and you know
no one has bad days or bad feelings
but it's a growing problem it's thought
more than a third of farmers could be
depressed and it particularly affects
those who are younger like matt who's
only 27.
when asked the majority of farmers
whatever their age said poor mental
health was a particular issue
but for those under 40 nine out of every
10 said it was the biggest hidden
problem they face
the research has been carried out by the
farm safety foundation its campaign mind
your head aims to encourage those who
are suffering to seek help
we want to normalize conversations about
mental well-being we want to talk about
it the same way we talk about going over
in our ankle or having an injury in a
five-a-side football match we all have
mental health good and bad yeah i've
just got a stench
former emmerdale star kelvin fletcher
bought his own farm in the peak district
last year and has seen firsthand just
how tough it can be
it's a massive responsibility it's a
sector that is
vital to society you know british
farmers produce the food for our plates
to the best standards in the world
uh you know and that kind of hard work
um
tends to sometimes come at a price
it's not unusual for matt to work 15
hours a day and switching off at bedtime
can be a battle he's found online
therapy and reaching out to other
farmers has helped him cope the dream is
to eventually become his own boss
full-time
he knows to achieve that he's as much
about managing his head as his business
emma birchley sky news cambridgeshire
let's go back to our top story now and
the prime minister is expected to lay
out his plan to end all covet
restrictions in england to mps when they
return to parliament this week including
ending self-isolation after a positive
test let's speak to dr ragib ali he's a
senior clinical research associate at
cambridge university dr ali thanks a lot
for talking to us so what do you make of
this is it a good idea
good morning and i think the first thing
to look at is the current covered
situation in
in england which fortunately on all
metrics now things are clearly improving
with hospitalizations
and deaths have been falling for some
time um even on the ons survey that we
get on a weekly basis it's clear that
infections
are falling now as well and so
our very high levels of population
immunity um as well as the care that
everyone's been taking personal
responsibility
and voluntary behavior change has really
kept
this wave much lower than we had feared
um so i think going forward
we would expect people to continue to
maintain that you know a certain level
of caution in their behavior we've
already seen that even after
the mandate for face mask was lifted
most people are still wearing face masks
even though there were no restrictions
on contacts over the last few months
people have still
kept their level of contact low and so i
think going forward even if the legal
requirement for people to stop
self-isolating
is not there
it's likely that the majority the vast
majority of people will continue to do
that because of course most people don't
want to infect other people
if they have symptoms and which are
consistent with covered or indeed any
respiratory illness
i think the guidelines should be very
clear to make it so that people know
that they shouldn't go to work they
certainly shouldn't be traveling on
public transport or meeting people who
are high risk
and as long as people continue to follow
their guidance um i think it's
reasonable to lift that legal
requirement
there is however the argument of people
um you know vulnerable people those who
suffered from long covert who say
it is a serious disease and we're not
taking it seriously enough
of course we need to have at the
forefront of our minds the needs of
those who are a higher risk from
clearbridge so many of my patients
are at high risk either because of their
age or because of
having
impaired immune systems and of course
that's why
as i said the care that everyone has
been taken and should people should
continue to do that as they have been
over the last few months for the
vulnerable people i would also encourage
them maybe this message doesn't go
across
as clearly as it should you know wearing
a good quality ffp
ffp two or three mask
does provide good protection to the
wearer that's the kind of masks that we
wear in hospital as frontline doctors so
although we're daily you know having
seen covered patients having covered
patients coughing on us
and most of us are wearing those good
quality masks haven't caught covered so
they do provide good protections even if
other people are not wearing masks you
know the person who's at risk themselves
if you wear a well-fitted good quality
mask
you are well protected from coverage so
that's an important massive thing that
needs to get out there because it is
essential as you say
um
to be responsible and to use those
freedoms responsibly
what are those masks call again dr ali
ffp2 or ffp3 masks also called m95
or kn 95 masks so they provide a better
fit they go over both the nose and the
mouth they don't have a gap at the edges
but the kind that we wear in hospitals
but they are available and i've bought
them myself online
for the general public as well
okay you said this wave now but do you
think
we could
see another variant that is more deadly
than omicron coming from a country which
doesn't have high vaccination rates do
you think we should be concerned going
forward so we certainly need to be
not complacent i mean we're currently in
a good position omicron unfortunately
has been less severe than previous
variants of population of industries
this would likely be the highest it's
it's ever been and we should continue
to ensure that people that haven't had
the vaccine yet
and come forward and offer the vaccine
particularly those who haven't had a
first or second days at all but even
those haven't had the boosters it's
never too late
of course new variants could come and
there's no guarantee that the new
variant when it comes because they will
come it's it's certain there will be new
variants there's no guarantee it will be
more
uh it will be milder than omicron or
they won't be as severe as previous
variants that's why i would advise
that we should continue our monitoring
certainly we should continue to sequence
um on a sample of covert infections to
see whether new variants are coming in
and we also recommend ongoing
surveillance with the ons infection
survey so we have a good idea of what
the problems of infection is in the
country in a different part of the
country and in different age groups so
that level of surveillance is going to
be important so we're best prepared as
possible for when the next parent
arrives
okay dr ali thank you so much for
talking to us have a nice sunday thank
you
let's have a look through the morning
papers now and joining me is the former
editor of the daily star dawn nesium and
journalist and broadcaster badisha there
they are dawn and bedisha thanks a lot
for hanging around um patisha why don't
you start the telegraph what are nhs
trusts going to be paid for
right well we know that nhs trusts are
going to receive funding from the
government but they also receive a sort
of extra top-up which is related to
elective surgery now we've all lived
through what we've lived over the last
two years and we know that when it comes
to surgery there have been delays in
necessary treatment necessary operations
ongoing treatment for long-standing
conditions and cancer treatments and now
the government are really trying to
say okay let's get this system back on
its feet but what they're doing seems
quite strange to me which is that
they're offering a sort of
top-up based on performance and they're
saying to nhs trust well the more
efficient you are the more patients you
can get in and out of the door we're
going to give you more funding based on
that and if you don't manage to do that
so if you don't prove your results and
your effectiveness well
why should we pay you any incentives and
that to me seems quite cruel because the
entire nation is on the side of the nhs
and the problem isn't
inefficiency or slowness it's under
funding it's under funding at the source
and so i really don't like to see the
government talking about are we going to
incentivize you for your performance
because as far as i'm concerned the
nhs's performance has always been
exceptional we're talking about quality
of care and quality of expertise what it
needs is money at the root and the
branch the infrastructure the payment
the salaries the support for nhs workers
the government are saying well actually
what they got what the people want to
see is you know they're paying increased
taxes they're paying increased national
insurance they want to know that they
get the services back again but i think
that sets up an unnecessary unnecessary
enmity
and cynicism between ordinary people and
the nhs i don't think the nhs needs to
be incentivized like that it needs
funding at the source
sunday express
sort of on the same thing the end of the
pandemic really or is it
dawn what is boss johnson set to
announce
right okay well this in theory is good
news i think it's good news personally
and the defiant boris will act all cobid
rules it's freedom day again you do have
a slight feeling of deja vu that we have
been here before
there's a cabinet meeting tomorrow on
monday
where boris is going to announce all
kobe draws are going to go and that will
apply as of february 24th which is
thursday so all happening very fast now
and this is going to end a legal duty on
people to
self-isolate if they test positive now
the bma have naturally said this is too
much too early and we shouldn't be doing
this and there are obviously accusations
that this is the dead cow or the dead
dog or whatever dead thing it is that
this week been flung on the table to
distract us all from boris's other
problems shall we say um to be honest
with you kimberly i'm not entirely sure
i care about the reasoning of it i'm
just glad that we are with the amazing
vaccination rollout coming through the
pandemic omicron as your doctor has been
saying earlier is a weaker virus we we
do have to learn to live with it and i
think you know most medics will agree
with that
interesting locally 50 of people do say
that even though all restrictions are
being removed
and this is obviously just in england
but they will continue to self-isolate
and and to keep social distancing and
many of them will be wearing mastering
public and this applies even more to
those who do feel particularly
vulnerable and aren't more at risk but
you know it's it's in in theory it's
good news and obviously the other part
of all this the big debate is whether
free testing um is going to come to an
end now the thing is kimberly it's not
free is it because it's the nhs paying
for it and it's costing us millions of
pounds to just hand out the test so
there's a big debate to be had about
whether testing is going to be so
important as we move forward on this one
it does feel like it is such a huge
moment for everyone does it and as you
said it's just in england
what do you think do you think people
are actually going to continue to
self-isolate even if they're not legally
bound to do so and do you think they're
going to be wearing their masks and
keeping their distance
by and large i think they are it's very
easy to get angry at the 10 or 20 of
people you see on the tube who are not
doing that or who are coughing all over
people but it's always been the case
that if you have any kind of illness
even just a cough or a cold you stay at
home
partly because just staying at home
makes you feel better but partly out of
consideration for other people you
wouldn't go into the office with a
stinking cold because you know it's
contagious so i do think that people do
have a certain degree of common sense
and i've been really heartened to see
that even though masks aren't mandatory
everywhere generally speaking there is
quite high compliance and i've actually
bought a range in various colors because
they tone with my
planned spring and summer outfits so i
have vanity reasons because i look
absolutely snappy in a mask so i have
lots and lots of reasons for it and i
also haven't had a cold in two and a
half years yeah they're quite a fashion
item now aren't they it's it's fun isn't
it
but anyway
talking of fun let's lighten things up
what is um jacob reese mog saying about
creme eggs dawn
oh i love this story we've gotta have
some fun it's a sunday morning uh right
because it's page 12 at the summit so
i'm gonna tiny story um
top tori obviously jacob rees-mogg says
he's hooked on cadbury's creme eggs and
this has been revealed because he only
agreed to go on have i got news for you
after bosses at the bbc one show sent
them a box of cadburys cream eggs it's
how many in a box i'm just wondering the
calendar
that's a lot i mean i like cream eggs
don't go there don't um his default
lunch in the rant to easter is a
sandwich and a cream egg for pudding and
it would be jacob bruce mogg who has
pudding wouldn't it
but his big worry this year kimberly is
that his nanny is finally going to
retire
she's 80
retire
oh dear man if i ate a creme egg every
day that would be
dire
are you vomiting you don't like cream
eggs
no they're so disgusting what's in them
it's so gross they make me gag
okay what about the caramel ones
oh
let's talk about holidays
oh they're going to get more expensive
what is this in the mail bedisha
yeah i'm sorry i mean once we've enjoyed
freedom day freedom spring and freedom
summer we're going to have very
expensive holidays we've been talking
about the fuel uh the rise in the cost
of fuel over the last several months
this is not some sort of new thing but
of course airline companies who are
suffering from all of that are going to
pass the cost onto the customer so
everybody wants to know what this
increase is going to be i'll give you
some benchmarks if you and your two kids
and your other half want to go to
disneyland this summer ordinarily you'd
pay around
950 pounds you're going to be being paid
paying around
1100 pounds so it's a few hundred pounds
increase uh that's if you book a
roundabout this spring for around about
august now all the signs are showing
that because we're so weary of covid
people are willing to take on board
those few hundred extra pounds in fact
the only people who don't want to pay
the extra are those who are oddly enough
wealthy enough to be taking several
holidays a year now that's not most
people is it
on the other hand lots of airline
experts are saying that companies are
going to be very cautious because
the the recovery we're having from covid
is actually quite fragile people are
very aware that the cost of living has
gone up the ordinary households so they
may scrimp and save on their holiday
this year and see how it plans out in
the long run it sounds like all we're
going to be able to do is sit around in
our fancy masks and eat cream eggs
we've got to leave it there
maybe not for you to badisha
thank you so much have a fantastic
sunday madisha dawn thank you